what started as a currency crisis in the
city is having a direct bearing on the
lives of households around the country
their hopes for prosperity for home
ownership now under threat for Rebecca
higher interest rates are another
obstacle to owning a home you've got all
the houses prices that have soared
you've then almost got a chance but
everything goes to auction
you've got a lot of products that came
onto the market originally but now
they've all been taken off the market
there just seems to be so many hurdles
and for me personally it just feels like
a never ending battle
the bank of England's Chief Economist
signaling today that it will do what
investors expect and lift the cost of
borrowing it's hard not to draw the
conclusion that all this will require a
significant monetary policy response
which means raising interest rates and
those comments has an immediate impact X
expectations for the max Benchmark
interest rate the one mortgages are
based off which only last month were
expected to Peak next year at 2.75
percent Rose to the highest level in
decades a six and a quarter percent
level for interest rates by next summer
and to add to the government's
difficulties after markets closed the
international monetary fund issued a
rare statement deploying language it
typically uses to describe emerging
economies
we are closely monitoring recent
economic developments in the UK and are
engaged with the authorities we do not
recommend large and untargeted fiscal
packages at this juncture as it is
important that fiscal policy does not
work at Cross purposes to monetary
policy furthermore the nature of the UK
measures will likely increase inequality
Professor Charlie Bean formerly of the
bank of England and office for Budget
responsibility there is a stark lesson
if it is to regain the Market's trust
the government needs to show it's
serious about the public finances which
could have uncomfortable consequences so
if you want to get a share of government
spending to GDP down you have to be
prepared say to move away from hiring a
Health Service which is free at the
point of delivery to one funded by
social insurance like they do in Germany
that's a massive
absolutely and and this is not a debate
politicians want to have I don't think
that kind of worms the chancellor took
advantage of a relatively calm day on
Market relatively to meet Financial
investors and reassure them about his
plan and what are the options well he
could do a U-turn not going to happen he
could assume the bank of England's going
to do its worse raise interest rates to
crippling levels with whatever that
implies for Middle England he could
introduce some of the toughest spending
cuts we have ever seen in this country
going further than any previous
governments none of those are palatable
options but then we have moved well
beyond talking about a growth plan or
the macro economy we're now talking
about credibility and once you lose
credibility it is very difficult to get
it back again
if there is a plan there was little clue
from any of the ministers coming and
going today
it's our worrying times lost Friday
morning Britain's economic prospects
looked much the same as the rest of
Europe today this country faces a weaker
currency weaker growth higher interest
rates and a crisis of confidence which
is still far from resolved at Conway Sky
News